a chairman of the intergovernmental
panel on climate change and also
director-general of the energy and
resources institute which is a
not-for-profit research institute
headquartered in New Delhi but we have a
presence in several parts of the world
including North America Europe Japan
Southeast Asia and the Middle East and
very soon we hope to be Africa as well
well I'm very happy to give you my views
on the Davos question I personally think
that we're at a critical juncture where
we could address the twin challenges of
meeting the energy needs of a growing
population and also fly to address the
problem of climate change by ensuring
that we mitigate the emissions of
greenhouse gases in the years ahead and
what I'd like to focus on is the very
severe and large problem that poor
people around the world are facing you
know they have well over a billion
people on this planet who have no access
to modern forms of energy and therefore
a number of them don't even know how to
get lighting once the Sun Goes Down some
of them are able to burn a candle some
are able to use a little lamb pools in
kerosene oil or other forms of oil but
quite apart from fact that those are
polluting options they certainly not
satisfactory and often they turn out to
be very expensive as well so what my
Institute has come up with is a set of
devices which include solar lanterns
these are photovoltaic based lanterns as
well as solar torches or flashlights if
you want to call them that and these use
LED lighting systems the benefit of
using these is that there are no running
costs because it's solar energy which
gives you
the lighting that one needs and what
we're trying to do is to promote these
on a large scale through a program that
I caught luck called lighting a billion
lights the effort is to see that
corporates governments foundations
around the world start looking at this
option and providing resources by which
poor people around the world can get
light into their lives this would make
such a difference to them because not
only would they be able to not only
would they be able to get lighting for
their own daily uses but think of the
benefits that young children might get
they might actually be able to prepare
their lessons they might be able to read
something in in several parts of the
world there's also a major challenge of
adult literacy elderly people who work
during the daytime can spend at least a
little bit of time in the evening trying
to get literate so essentially this is a
highly viable technology just to give
you an example a solar torch costs no
more than ten dollars or less than eight
euros and a solar Lantern costs the
equivalent of about seventy dollars and
with this set of devices you can really
take care of the needs of the whole
world having said so we need an
institutional arrangement because every
village where you need to disseminate
this particular technology would have to
have a local representative someone who
can carry out very minor repairs not
that repairs are required with this
technology and can also act as the
source for marketing these devices so
there is need to create a market-based
local institutional infrastructure
now what I would submit is that anyone
who wants information on this can get in
touch on the website of my Institute
which is the energy and resources
institute the website address is te RI I
n dot o RG Terry n dot o RG and you can
get all the information you require on
this particular set of options and we're
hoping that if we are fortunate if we
have the kind of dedication that one is
looking for that in the next three or
four years we might be able to cover the
entire planet and provide those who have
no means for modern lighting systems to
get get access to these technologies and
literally light up a billion lights so
this is what I wanted to share with you
and I hope we can make a major beginning
in this year because this would not only
address the critical need for energy as
far as the poorest people in the world
are concerned but also find suitable
solution for mitigating the emissions of
greenhouse gases or potential emissions
of being a special in the future thank
you